reaction house ways and means committee
chairman Jason Smith he's from Missouri
sir
to see you
great to be with you Sean
all right I wanna I wanna talk at length
about exactly what these these IRS
whistleblowers told you because you know
we have this 1023 whistleblower that the
FBI obviously deemed credible because
they had paid him hundreds of thousands
of dollars for past intelligence so my
question is let's go over what these two
whistleblowers were telling you and your
committee
absolutely you know we set up a
whistleblower hotline and my first week
as chairman and we've had a lot of
whistleblowers come forward but they
started out basically what you will find
in their 14 hours worth of testimony is
that the federal government has a
two-tiered justice system they don't
treat all taxpayers see the same
unfortunately uh Americans aren't just
average Americans aren't treated the
same way that wealthy and the
politically connected especially if your
last name's Biden and we saw that with
countless examples that they used how
the Department of Justice intervene in
the prosecution of Hunter Biden They
delayed they divulged and they denied
numerous examples of where these
investigators tried to go into uh
further prosecution of Hunter Biden so
by delaying that that allow the statute
of limitations to pass so that other tax
issues that likely would have come up
from say 2014 and onward he would have
been charged with those and and likely
they would have been felonies is that a
fair statement that's right the
whistleblowers actually showed that in
the tax years of 2014 and 2015 uh Hunter
Biden on a conservative estimate would
have owed three hundred thousand dollars
in unpaid taxes for his foreign
resources that he received and because
they delayed the statute of limitations
has expired for any criminal penalties
for 2014 and 2015 tax years let me go
and and let me go to this Chinese
business partner and let me go to this I
guess WhatsApp is an encrypted app that
people use
um to prevent any type of spying or or
it erases itself it disappears uh is
that would that be a a proper
characterization
that's exactly right it's a it's a
messaging app and what was what was
brought to our attention by the IRS
whistleblowers is that in fact there was
a documented a message on Hunter Hunter
Biden's WhatsApp account that went to a
a Chinese business partner like what you
said Sean and it was pretty much
demanding for that that business partner
to contact him in regards to a future
payment and he highlighted that he is
sitting right next to his father waiting
for his response and that absolutely
contradicts what President Biden has
said on numerous occasions that he knows
nothing about his son Hunter Biden's
business dealings why did we not hear
about this before and I want us I want
to read this again I'm sitting here with
my father and would like to understand
why the commitment made has not been
fulfilled I will make certain that
between the man sitting next to me he's
talking about Joe Biden and every person
he knows and my ability to hold the
grudge that you will regret not
following my direction I am sitting here
waiting for the call with my father now
congressman is there anything more
incriminating of Joe Biden than that
encrypted message uh that he has with a
Chinese business partner
it definitely says a lot right there and
that's very disturbing that's why it is
so important that the American people
get this information it's so important
that the house Ways and Means Committee
voted today to allow this information to
be public because of statutory
authorities under something they call
6103 we were the only ones able to have
the information from the IRS
whistleblowers and in order for that
information to be made public we had to
vote to make it public that's why we did
it is so that the public can see this
information they can hear it and the
facts can continue to lead to further
further progress so the three countries
that I referred to what was a China
Romania and and one other country and
Ukraine and Ukraine it was 17 million
dollars and of that 17 million you've
been able to trace back uh over 8
million to 100 Biden that he received
himself
right at 8.3 million and when you look
at the different uh payments and Gifts
Hunter Biden received a Porsche valued
over a hundred and forty thousand
dollars you received it he got the
Porsche from the guy in Kazakhstan
didn't he get a car from that guy too
yeah I don't know I don't recall who
it's from I just remember being like a
free card like a Z06 Corvette if they
can get me one with the z07 package I'm
on a list to get one but my name hasn't
been called yet I'm waiting what Hannity
if you change your last name to Biden
you might get that card
uh touche congressman
you know what I think I'll stick with
the name I have uh uh even though in
some circles uh maybe not well but but
let me go to the length and the depths
that the doj went to to protect the
entire family and the family Syndicate
or the family Enterprise here because
everything that these whistleblowers
were telling us uh just lends itself to
an argument that the doj knew that they
had cause and and reasonable suspicion
and that they purposely did nothing and
that they gave the Biden special
treatment uh is that consistent with
what your interpretation of these two
whistleblowers are
yeah the whistleblowers both of them
pointed out some very alarming
um activities of the Department of
Justice they pointed out how the
Department of Justice had been delaying
um the tactics in the investigation
which ultimately led to the statute of
limitations expiring in
2014-2015. they also provided
information showing that department of
justice prosecutors in fact let Hunter
Biden's attorneys know of search
warrants being issued for example they
had a search warrant where they were
going to go after a storage unit he had
Northern in Northern Virginia and they
had contacted Hunter Biden's attorneys
beforehand that that is absolutely
unreasonable and something that
typically doesn't happen we also have a
lot of evidence from the whistleblowers
it shows that there is in fact not
Independence as as attorney general
Garland had said in numerous testimony I
mean before the United States Senate all
right Congressman incredible work a lot
of courage and bravery one last thing
these whistleblowers I thought Democrats
love whistleblowers even hearsay
whistleblowers but apparently there's
been retribution to them
there absolutely has been retribution
according to the whistleblowers and
that's something that we are going to
take aggressive measures and looking in
um both of these whistleblowers after
they came out have been removed from
that investigation that they have been
part of since 2018. chairman great job
and I hope the American people are
paying attention because if we don't
have equal justice we don't have equal
uh application of our laws if we have a
two-tier justice system we might as well
take that document known as our
Constitution and shred it because it's
meaningless great job sir thank you we
appreciate you being with us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else